[Music]
when it comes to the sacred italian
staple you'll be hard-pressed to find
anyone who knows more than pastor
supremo antonio sakamani
i love pasta so much i have to eat it at
least once a day
he's been selling perfect pasta in
london soho for over 35 years and eating
great pasta for a lifetime
we make the best pass in the world
italy
takes away the past in italy and the
people died you know and that's it for a
good very good pasta you need two
ingredients you need a good egg and very
good flour and that's it this is a durum
wheat flour look at that it's so soft
does it cooks so quick a couple minutes
in a boiling water this thing like this
couple minutes it's cool
this shop is not it's not big enough to
store all the type of pasta this is the
famous
spaghettoni albronzo this is penne
different shape it's called fusilli
antonio's right there's a mind-blowing
array of incredible pasta types that are
great to keep in your store cupboard
here's my quick guide to some of the
different shapes and sizes and how to
use them
small shapes like farfelini are perfect
for making simple stews and soups more
substantial and add an extra texture to
dishes like the classic italian pasta
soup minestrone
short tubes like penne are great for
thick cream or tomato based sauces as
the rigid edges hold more sauce for an
incredibly flavored packed mouthful
long and thin like the store covered
essential spaghetti the classic shape
was invented in naples but every italian
region has its own spaghetti dish from
bolognese to carbonara or my favorite a
lavongale which is spaghetti with
delicious steamed clams
flat noodles shaped strands like
fettuccine are perfect with a simple
drizzle of olive oil or in rich buttery
dishes as a little sauce goes a long way
coating the pasta evenly stopping the
strands from sticking together
then pass the sheets not just great for
lasagnas but amazing rolled into tubes
and filled to make delicious cannelloni
or used in quick supper dishes like my
mushroom and leek pasta
finally speciality pastas like this
spaghetti made with squid ink has
delicately sweet taste and an amazing
jet black color great for when you want
a delicious dinner that's a little bit
different
whatever shape you go for always look
out for the pastas that have been bronze
cut
it means the dough was pressed through a
bronze cutting dye which has a subtle
rough texture which helps the sauce
stick as well as all the dried types
pasta also comes fresh which is
brilliant for tv dinners because it
cooks super quick and tastes incredible
too
in this shop we make pasta every day
look at that that's beautiful
it's sad to eat it this pasta is really
really yellow because we use good
quality of eggs
you can
smell the eggs they come through
it's so good so fresh you can even
eat it raw like that
it lasts in a fridge two or three days
you can even freeze it and you want
chain taste whether fresh or dried pasta
so versatile and quick to cook is the
perfect tv dinner so go out stock up on
new shaves and you'll soon be turning
out dishes that would make pasta pro
antonio very proud he looks so nice so
good so healthy
you know and that's it it can resist
making your enochy is so simple to do
yet the results are absolutely stunning
and it's a great way of using up
leftover baked potatoes
you can make noki just with flour and
eggs however the potato gives it a nice
light sort of creamy fluffy texture cut
them in half take your spoon and scoop
the inside of those potatoes
i'm using leftover baked potatoes but
this really works as well with leftover
ball potatoes two choices you can get a
fork and sort of mash the potato and get
it nice and light and fluffy or
this little gadget is called a ricer i
suppose it's a posh word
for a potato masher just squeeze gently
you can see how nice and light it is
almost like fluffy little strands of
potato
you can do this when the potatoes are
hot it'll go through the rice so much
quicker
just slice that off there
now
a nice spoon of ricotta ring a little
touch of salt and pepper it's really
important to season the mixture as we go
along otherwise the nokia becomes really
bland
flour over the ricotta sieved so there's
no lumps
one delicious egg give that a little
whisk
now
make a little well in the center
you want a nice soft
pliable ball of dough
give that a really good mix
get some thyme flowers in there
and this time is light fragrant and it's
just a really nice herb and with the
ricotta
it tastes brilliant just pick the little
tips the time flowers
next flower your hands generously and
knead the mixture into a dough
fold in and push and basically what it's
doing is get it nice and smooth
as it starts to get a little bit wet
and just add a little touch of flour we
want something really nice and soft now
don't overwork it
it stops the nokia from expanding when
it hits the pan
that's exactly what i want a nice sort
of soft
fragrant ball cut the ball in half
lightly flour
the hands and just roll it
gently
just think of a a big long cigar
the mixture will start getting a little
bit sort of wetter but do not add lots
of flour
now
lightly flour the knife so when you
slice the gnocchi it doesn't stick
cut the dough into bite-sized pieces
just take your finger dip it in the
flour and push down
why i want my knocking to look like a
pillow
and for most important part there is
that not one of them are identically the
same shape
water on
bring up to the boil little touch of
olive oil in there
lightly flour your hand
lift up the nokia
in to the rolling boiling water
turn that pan to stop them from sticking
at the bottom and let them simmer and
they start to sort of tell you they're
cooked when they start floating get a
pan on get that nice and hot now they're
just starting to come up to the top and
you can continue cooking them like that
i like blanching them in the water
taking them out and then frying them to
study the gnocchi heat olive oil in a
frying pan
gently lift up and look they've doubled
in size
drain it get rid of the excess water and
straight in to the hot pan
[Music]
this is where they start to take on a
completely different texture nice crisp
sauteed texture on the outside
nokia loves fresh pepper
so
pepper in
you can see as i start turning them i've
got this really nice little sort of
brown
color
and they're almost popping up now like
little parcels so i want them nice and
sauteed both sides but light
and creamy
in the center
fresh garden peas
in
and the butter gives it a really nice
sort of
bernoulli flavor on the end
beautiful
a little bit of fresh thyme over the
peas and then finally i want to lift it
up fresh lemon
zest the lemon over
[Music]
smells incredible
and then finally seal the deal with a
touch of grated piles and cheese give
your veg some attitude and you'll get
amazingly elegant dishes on a budget
that are always guaranteed to impress
what more do you want from great cooking
cheap to make easy to cook and
absolutely stunning
first up pasta with tomatoes anchovies
and chilies
[Music]
for the spicy sauce slice anchovies
and garlic
[Music]
next dried chilies great for keeping in
the cupboard add a hit of heat on demand
[Music]
then add the anchovy oil to a hot pan
and fry the chopped ingredients
add half cherry tomatoes
[Music]
chopped black olives and salted capers
cook to combine the flavours
[Music]
in a separate pan
boiled dried spaghetti another great
store-covered staple
when the pasta is tender but still firm
drain
add to the sauce with a splash of the
water it's full of starch which gives a
great silky consistency
then season with pepper and topped with
basil
packed with big bold flavors and ready
in under 20 minutes pasta with tomatoes
anchovy and chilis farfally with ricotta
pancetta and peas
[Music]
start by frying lardons in a large pan
these smoked chunks of bacon have a
delicious deep salty flavor that makes
them perfect with pasta
when the lavender start to brown add
finely chopped garlic and turn off the
heat
next add farfeli to boiling salted water
[Music]
named after the italian for butterflies
this bow tied shaped pasta has a large
surface area great for sticking to
sauces
just before the pasta is ready add
frozen peas to the boiling past the
water
then when the pasta and the peas are
cooked drain and add to the lardons and
the garlic
spoon in creme fraiche
[Music]
and dot with lumps of creamy ricotta
cheese
[Music]
season
then serve
ready in just 12 minutes
farfeli with ricotta pancetta and peas
a delicious quick and easy supper that's
ready when you are
[Music]
my next pronto pasta dish
is taglitelli with quick sausage meat
bolognese
[Music]
first boiled dry taglitelli and salted
water these long thin ribbons of pasta
come curled up in nests and take around
10 minutes to cook
then add olive oil to a hot pan
and fry finely chopped onion
thinly slice garlic
and sweat until soft
[Music]
next remove the meat from your sausages
by cutting open their skins and crumble
into the pan
fennel or sicilian sausages are perfect
for this dish but any flavor sausage
will do
when the meat has browned add half
cherry tomatoes
season
[Music]
and add a few spoonfuls of the pasta
cooking water as the starch thickens the
sauce and helps it stick to the pasta
drain the teglatelli and add to the
sausage meat sauce
[Music]
finish with freshly grated parmesan
[Music]
perfect when you're really busy but
still want great tasting food fast my
amazing taglitelli with quick sausage
meat bolognese
[Applause]
my final pasta dish that's ready in a
flash and packs a real flavor punch
a spaghetti with chili sardines and
oregano
[Music]
first for the crunchy topping heat olive
oil in a frying pan
add chopped garlic
and breadcrumbs
[Music]
cook over medium heat until the bread
crumbs are golden
season
and drain on kitchen paper
for the sauce add the oil from your
sardines to a hot pan
fry finely diced chili
and chopped garlic
next cook dry spaghetti in boiling water
then chop tin sardines into chunks
and add to the chili and garlic tin
sardines are a brilliantly versatile
ingredient to have in your cupboard
packed with protein full of super
healthy omega-3 oils and delicious
next drain your pasta and combine with
the sardine chili and garlic mixture
add leaves of fresh oregano
and mix in handfuls of rocket
to serve pile high and top with the
crispy garlic breadcrumbs
[Music]
ready in under 15 minutes spaghetti with
chili sardines and oregano healthy
hearty and full of flavor perfect pasta
in moments
my delicious mushroom and leek pasta
this fantastic fast and simple pasta
dish made with everyday ingredients just
goes to prove you can eat good food
whenever you want
really important put the water on first
so you can just have it gently simmering
away ready for the pasta
while the water comes to the boil start
the sauce by slicing mushrooms first off
fingers one in front two behind
up and
down then add olive oil to a hot frying
pan
[Music]
i want that nice color on the mushrooms
off the heat literally 10 seconds
and when you toss something really
important you get all the ingredients at
the end of the pan
push down and pull back
that noise that
that's all the water coming out of the
mushrooms
next finely chop a fat clove of garlic
then prepare your leeks
just take your knife
and go down
through the center turn it over
and again into quarters
see all that opening up and then just
rinse the top of that to get rid of any
potential dirt or sand
it just breaks up into nice little
quarters
add
all that leek
into those mushrooms
beautiful
and now the secret is to get rid of that
water inside the leak
as it cooks down all the water's gone
you just left that really nice intense
flavor
garlic nice and crispy
now we're gonna add a touch of chicken
stock in there
beautiful
lasagna sheets just gonna drop the
sheets
in to the water
lasagna sheets are an unusual choice for
a dish like this but they work
brilliantly although any type of pasta
you've got in the cupboard will do
and just twist that pan
that stops any pasta actually sticking
to the bottom of the pan
chicken start to reduce down by half
and it's almost delays the bottom of the
pan basically washed all that wonderful
flavor off turn the gas down and add a
couple of tablespoons of cream
this just enriches the dish bring it
back up to the bowl and let it simmer
for three to four minutes
now
the secret with the pasta is just taking
it out a little early so you've got that
nice texture
hold up the sheet and just nip it
and you can feel your fingers in the
center it's ready
turn the sauce down
and lay
these beautiful sheets
of lasagna into that sauce
i'm just gonna turn the gas off now
and let the pasta sit in there and
absorb that amazing sauce
finish with chopped fresh tarragon
it's a delicious herb that goes
brilliantly well mushrooms and leeks
just let that sit and almost sort of
infuse
to serve i'm making a quick bruschetta
by toasting fresh chipata bread two nice
slices drizzle that
in olive oil
a little bit of garlic
just rub the bread
the crust as well crust is what really
takes that garlic
now
pan for the bread little touch of olive
oil as it starts to smoke
bread in
[Music]
but look at the pasta now it's been
stained by that amazing sauce to serve i
want a nice spoon of my mushrooms leeks
and cream
then i'll take my pasta
just twist it
and let it sit on top
that tarragon has just lifted everything
bread on
and that's the beauty about something so
simple they can be done in 20 minutes
with everyday ingredients a stunning
pasta dish
adding easy and versatile dishes like
this to your repertoire is what cooking
at home is all about so you can always
make great tasting food at the drop of a
hat